welcome to this video playing step by
step from Bulgaria it's got a very high
rating of course it goes up and down all
the time but this is one of his higher
ratings okay I'll play the age three
again okay not the exchange and this
bloody line again keep forgetting to
look up something decent against this
it's a it's night h5 is tricky for white
and as mentioned i wanted to want it to
look up something but i forgot it ok i
95 and g4 well this one I don't know oh
it's very complicated
hmm
night h5 is a move that had a very
dubious reputation for a long time
another very dubious orbiter that's a
bit too much but it wasn't believed to
be the best way to play and then there
was something i discovered in the the
main line with the peace sacrifice after
the I think night h2 is the normal move
and I know that I want to avoid this but
I keep forgetting to check what they
play nowadays against Knight h5 and then
I need to I don't know no I know I don't
know about need to but then I start to
play this kind of improvised things
which do not really do not really a post
many problems like I mean this is this
probably here is not terrible for white
but it's also certainly not not the best
what you can do enough okay with this
this I start to like again maybe not a
bishop d for an IG two III this kind of
maneuvers are possible
no that's that's okay really this is an
ok position
rook g12 cover g3 and yeah on a very
very good day white manages to play g4
on the favorite circumstances but not
sure this is one of those days very
tough to manage but it's okay I'm just
as it is okay so I going to try to push
this okay so he put some pressure here
maybe I need to cover this
hey that's not so easy to play actually
it's now tough for me to to do anything
positive in this position
okay I don't like to do this but maybe I
need to
also not so easy for black to improve
its bishop and night are not doing so
much i will need to have a patty Peter
sir do something useful okay I actually
have a plan I can do this to see you
want to route to queen is seven rook
here oak takes rook takes Queen maybe
maybe Queenie seven is really a plan
okay I have an idea anyway let's let's
do this intending night f2h 3g5 this
would help me enormously route you to
route 22 Queen h4h three so I'm save
them
now the night on g5 would really render
his heavy pieces a bit useless on the G
file that's maybe a good plan check
taking h5 not this was probably not
really leading to much draw our third no
not really I'm not already not sure
about the merits of the position but
it's nobody need to to make it wrong
guindy one check
you had a position I don't know it
wasn't easy to play for 44 black as well
black forfeits on time yo no idea um
yeah was was tough to play was tough to
play probably prolly this is about equal
I mean he's got this act of Blue Ivy
pieces but how do you really get get
ahead worth with black I don't really I
don't really know the night on g5 really
am is helping me yeah yeah I don't know
how I could have prevented that it here
I can always attack the porn a bit
Bishop Bishop d one was better doing
this doing this straight away something
like this yeah the problem is I can also
not really easily open up the position
as the night on c5 and this is whole
formation is a block on the queenside so
it probably should be about about equal
still but okay II blundered blunt at the
porn on h5 he goes just look aged 8 to
cover that we're in a position where
it's very difficult to make any any
headway for for both sides but there is
really no need to accept the draw yeah
I've got more than one minute extra on
the clock and there is still fight in
the position it's not like it's a dead
draw but it's it's tough to make
progress I mean I would like to get in a
three before somehow make make this
night go away but I don't really see how
know it's probably equal it's probably
equal alright thanks for watching